depuis que notre espèce a levé les yeux
vers le ciel pour la première fois, nous avons rêvé d'atteindre
Mars en 2029, ce rêve est devenu réalité
lorsque les premiers humains ont posé le pied sur la
planète rouge et dans quelques mois, un nouveau
groupe d'astronautes fera le
voyage c'est un  des entreprises les plus ambitieuses de l'humanité le
résultat direct
d'une course spatiale mondiale de plusieurs décennies et
d'une mission conjointe créée pour étendre
l'exploration humaine aux
confins de notre système solaire
c'est l'histoire d'Ares notre plus grande
aventure
voici l'Hermès
le plus complexe et le plus  machine coûteuse
jamais construite, nous n'en avons construit qu'une et il
reste Harvard et l'orbite terrestre basse
entre les missions, les
astronautes comptent sur des navettes pour voyager
jusqu'aux genoux et à partir de là, ils
embarquent pour une croisière parfaitement contrôlée,
mais ne vous y trompez pas, ce n'est pas un
voyage facile le  le voyage vers Mars est aussi dangereux
et difficile que tout ce que nous avons jamais
essayé, le voyage moyen s'enregistre à
140 millions de miles et tout au long du
voyage, Hermès et son équipage sont b  ombardés
par des radiations cosmiques qui
endommageraient irréversiblement leur ADN si ce n'était pour
la protection du vaisseau et si cela ne suffisait pas les
éruptions solaires les astéroïdes et les
météores représentent une menace catastrophique pour
la mission une frappe majeure pourrait laisser
Hermès bloqué dans l'
environnement hostile de l'espace sans  espoir de
sauvetage à condition que tout se passe comme
prévu l'équipage d'Ares 3 arrivera en
orbite martienne 124 jours plus tard prêt à
descendre à la surface une fois sur Mars ils
passeront un mois dans un habitat conçu
pour les protéger des tempêtes de poussière et des températures à faible teneur en oxygène et à rayonnement élevé
qui peut plonger à 100 degrés en dessous de zéro
malgré ces défis, l'équipage
enquêtera en profondeur sur l'
histoire biologique de la planète et son potentiel à
cultiver et à maintenir la vie en fonction de
ce qu'ils apprendront.
colonie examinant
une nouvelle aventure qui nous emmènera encore
plus loin dans les étoiles au-dessus de la
terre un magnifique wo  rld auquel nous
devons notre création ne semble plus
destiné à être notre dernier lieu de repos
notre aventure ne fait que commencer
au nom de Startalk nous souhaitons à
l'équipage d'Ares 3 un bon voyage
Godspeed Hermes et comme toujours continuez
à vous regarder